dirait que ça sert sa masse et ça m'a
énormément blanc celle de vous parce que
je sais que vous êtes un humaniste voilà
et c'est vrai que c'est tout ce que vous
aimez pas je suis sensible à ça alors
moi je vais vous répondre je combats le
racisme sous toutes ses formes et de
sensibilité je condamne autant
la profanation du carré musulman à
mulhouse que l'attaqué contre une
procession catholique à nanterre mais ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui
musulmans de france sont stigmatisés et
qui sont stigmatisés parce qu'ils sont
musulmans et moi je le dis et je sais
que je suis minoritaire et je le dis
quand milla attaque beaucoup la religion
musulmane moi personnellement j les
jeunes représentent que moi ça me gêne
je trouve que la religion chacun le
droit de la vie tranquillement
paisiblement chez lui couvert les
blasphèmes excusé briller oui mais mes
joueurs je suis sincère vous n'êtes vous
pas vous parler walker vous parlez je
parle dit ce que je ressens moins voilà
de leçon à personne et je le dis et je
sais que cette position elle peut être
compter ses vrais comptes et je le sais
mais moi ça me non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que moi ça me gêne quand on
attaque les religions parce que je
trouve que chacun doit pouvoir vivre
tranquillement franc je relis sa
religion donc j'ai trouvé que certaines
des attitudes ou des mots ou des
provocations de mila était pour moi
choquant et je les dis et je ne regrette
pas de l'avoir dès maintenant je
condamne tout aussi fermement que vous
les menaces et à l'encontre d'ange allez
vous dire est ce que vraiment vous
d'abord qu'on a le droit de critiquer
les religions je le sais alors non mais
juste une chose c'est que évidemment
c'est assez je comprends qu'on puisse ne
pas entendre la nuance entre critiquer
une religion et dénoncer les croyants
mais ça n'est pas la même chose je suis
navré mais ça n'est pas la même chose en
plus moi je considère et vous n'êtes pas
d'accord qu'il ya un problème spécifique
aujourd'hui d'acculturation de l'islam
mais ça c'est normal vous la salle
étaient tombés d'accord mais non mais ça
veut dire que ces pots explique démarche
dans la vie d'un grand média lui non
mais justement où devait plus la rentrée
non vous devez pouvoir entendre des
choses avec lesquelles vous n'êtes pas
d'accord voilà je suis navré c'est comme
ça il ya une enquête il ya une semaine
qu'il nous dise 60% +2 60%
lycéen musulman ou des lycéens croyants
musulmans considèrent que l'islam et au
su de la république si vous ne trouvez
pas que c'est un problème si vous pensez
si vous voulez que tout ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui les je ne parle même pas des
attentats je parle simplement de ce
qu'on appelle le sépare at il dû au fait
que les juifs ont quitté l'école
publique antenne samedi c'est pas pour
rien si vous voulez et bien il y a quand
même beaucoup de gens qui ne pique pas
paisiblement leur format 19 fournir des
musulmans en france vient tranquillement
leur nom il ya % qui l'ont condamné
après dany ces maisons les tombes les
études montrent le contraire tous
faisaient une montre qu'il ya une grosse
minorité de 30% toutes les études le
montrent cnrs institut me lancer justin
10 avec les abattre c'est moi le débat
c'est pas le jeu là j'aurais vraiment
c'est dans les jambes arquées là dessus
je verrai peut rien c'est pas c'est pas
le sujet on en reparlera délirant jeudi
soir d'accord avec avec eric zemmour
mais c'est vrai que passionné ça n'est
pas le sujet la ccl plus gilbert délé
mois lorsque dit gilles verdez je vais
vous dire ce qui produit de verdun et je
connais un petit peu et on entend
tellement de choses aujourd'hui de
discours en direct à la télévision
anti-musulmans qu' il ya beaucoup de
musulmans je vous le dis qu'ils qui
commence à vraiment à se replier sur eux
mêmes il exauce plus sortir ils n'osent
plus aller faire des sorties ils sortent
les hausses plus parler et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression aussi
que vraiment il ya une stigmatisation
sur les musulmans sur différentes
émissions sur différentes antennes sur
différents discours qu'on peut entendre
et on voit la campagne qui a démarré
elle est extrêmement à droite elle et
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas un candidat qui
ne parle pas des musulmans ou de l'islam
donc vous comprenez bien que deschamps
qui m'a qui nous regardent et les
personnes qui auraient raté les visions
les personnes qui regardent un meeting
un moment ils se disent on a
l'impression qu'on veut pas de nous dans
ce pays et ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué pas de certaines banques ça
devient plus compliqué plus en plus
compliqué pour les musulmans aussi de
vivre en france je lis il sait ce que tu
voulais dire je pense justement c'est ce
que je voulais dire c'est que ils se
sentent rejetés et ça le pire moi j'en
connais beaucoup des allemands devraient
commencer à dire mais nous on est
rejetée alors que nous très dur on irait
très dur français comme tous les
français on est rendus normalement
voilà mais oui c'est ça qu'on veut et
pas seulement des papiers la france
s'est aussi des moeurs et une culture
non excusez moi par exemple quand vous
allez au musée moi mais quand vous avez
zappé dans les morts je ne peux pas
aller dans certaines banlieues habillé
comme je m'amusais avec vous allonger
pour le volet vous permettiez est basé
si vous voulez vous avez vous des mini
habillé comme vous voulez mais l avis de
m et et gilles verdez en minijupe savoir
si vous n'êtes pas le gagnant tous les
deux je voulais tout moins bonne mais ce
qui me terrifie c'est que vous ne voyez
pas vous ne voyez pas ce qui saute aux
yeux vous croyez quoi que les français
sont devenus tout d'un coup se dire ils
sont dit vraiment on sait qu'il ya pas
de problème avec l'islam durer
énormément des nourrisons mais c'est un
frère musulman de l'islam qui est un
problème